[Music]
if there's one movie that's taking the
world by storm its to all the boys I've
loved before this film showcases actors
Lana Condor and Noah Santonio who just
so happened to have amazing on-screen
chemistry watch until the end to find
out which epic movie scene didn't
require a script first time on the
things don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and give this video a
big thumbs up now let's jump right into
the unscripted moments from the all the
boys I've ever loved before a movie the
EDM concert when you're an actor you're
expected to be quick on your feet after
all mistakes can happen when the camera
is rolling and you're expected to go
with the flow with this in mind many
actors make it a point to study
improvisation tactics and with good
reason to to all the boys I've loved
before is by far one of the most
anticipated Netflix chick flicks of 2018
countless fans waited for this movie to
be released and they weren't
disappointed if you clicked on this
video it's probably because you're
crushing on Peter Kaminsky and want to
find out if his actions were real or
fake well before we give you the inside
scoop let's switch our focus to Laura
Jean and her best bud Chris actress
Madeline Arthur is the beauty behind
Chris's character this fun and eccentric
character does and says whatever comes
to her mind and the same can be said
about Madeline's do you remember when
Laura Jean and Chris were on their way
to the ski trip if so you can probably
recall Chris talking about her late
night excursion at an EDM concert after
Lara Jean curved Peter and chose to sit
down with Chris on the bus the two gal
pals started talking about the previous
night's events
Chris who is clearly recovering from an
intense night out stays quiet for most
of the trip however when they get closer
to the ski resort Lara Jean confronts
her about going to an EDM concert on a
school night being the carefree
individual that she is Chris just
comments on the fact that it wasn't an
EDM concert it was more of a rock themed
party and it wasn't
like this scene flowed flawlessly and
definitely sounds as though it was
scripted
truth is however that it was purely made
up by Madeline and Lana if there's one
thing we can't help but notice it's that
every single actor in this movie seems
to be completely at ease with their cast
members and let's face it we wouldn't
have it any other way
Lara jeans adorable facial expressions
there's no use denying that actress Lana
Condor is absolutely adorable the young
actress poured her heart and soul into
her character and she managed to nail
apart what set her apart from the other
candidates was her obvious chemistry
with actor Noah Santonio who had already
been casted for the role in order for
Lana to be cast as Lara Jean she had to
do a chemistry read with her on-screen
lover Peter and she blew it out of the
park from the get-go directors noticed
how calm and comfortable the actors were
together and this helped them make a
decision
during an interview Noah admitted to
fighting Lana's facial expressions
downright hilarious he said that during
their initial chemistry read he had to
go off-script and point out how judging
her face looked as a result of this
directors chose to incorporate his line
in the actual movie in the end they
found it to be raw and factual
throughout the film
Lana allowed her facial expressions to
speak for themselves and is only at a
depth to her character every cute
eyebrow quirk or little smirk was indeed
unscripted but undoubtedly encouraged
the young actress managed to find her
character's voice by being herself and
that's what we call a perfect match
author Jenny Han is the mastermind
behind - all the boys I've loved before
and she made it a point to root for an
Asian American actress to play the role
of Laura Jean sadly she had to fight for
her vision because many production
companies wanted to whitewash the
character after putting her foot down
ponds vision came to life bringing forth
the one and only Laura Condor to think
that a different actress could have
played this part is hard to believe
after all no one could have done a
better job than Lana
Lara jeans lock screen picture if
there's one thing every director wants
it's for his main actors to get along
after all there's nothing worse than
having to play the mediator between two
leading protagonists what makes to all
the boys I've loved before such an
amazing movie is how genuine and
comfortable the main actors seemed to be
together
luckily the same can be said about them
when they're not being filmed in order
to enhance their bond Lana and Noah made
it a point to hang out before the movie
began its final filming scheduled to do
this the actor
attended hot yoga classes together which
definitely allowed them to get up close
and personal after becoming good pals
the actors were able to let loose on set
which helped their chemistry flourish
throughout the movie we see Lara Jean
and Peters snapping selfies of one
another and posting it on social media
in one scene Peter even takes a picture
of Lara Jean and puts it as his
background
afterwards he beckons her to do the same
claiming that that's what real couples
do towards the end of the movie we catch
a glimpse of Lara jeans lockscreen
picture and see an adorable photo of her
and Peter cuddling this photo sort of
catches us off guard
especially since it was taken from a
third party perspective after poking
around for some info it was revealed
that the photograph was in fact a
real-life photo of Lana and Noah
cuddling offset turns out that the
actors wanted to take a nap between
filming schedules and found themselves
in each other's arms
director Susan Johnson found them in
this embrace and decided to snap a pic
of the raw moment the fact that Lana and
Noah are this close is definitely
surprising especially since cuddling is
such a personal and intimate action the
on-screen lovebirds decided to post
their picture online which caused an
uproar of excited fans to wonder if the
pair were truly an item while their
relationship is strictly friendly we
can't help but wish that these two would
end up together
the hot tub scene if there's one scene
we just can't shake it's the heated hot
tub scene at this point of the movie
many of us thought that Lara Jean and
Peter were never going to get together
mainly because Laura Jean was too blind
to see that Peter was crushing on her
and not Jen after speaking to Lucas
about her problems he tells her that
Peter is most likely waiting for her in
the hot tub alone and heartbroken
despite not believing him Lara Jean
still makes it a point to go check out
the hot tub just in case and to her big
surprise Peter is exactly where Lucas
said he'd be as soon as Laura Jean
enters the scene things get a little
heated they start bickering about why
Lara Jean didn't sit next to him on the
bus and she tells him that he should be
happy that she didn't after all in the
end he got to sit next to Jen the woman
he wants to be with after hearing this
Peter splashes some water away from him
Cox's head to the side and rolls his
eyes this cute gesture is totally
something Peter would do but did you
know that after Noah sent nao actually
improvised the scene as well Noah came
up with this move to express his
frustration and his director absolutely
loved it afterwards
Peter went on to tell Lara Jean that she
may have good grades but she can be a
little dense sometimes despite saying
this Lara Jean still remains with a
shocked expression on her face clearly
indicating that she's gonna need a
confession from him to make her believe
him Peter tells her that he was so
excited to sit next to her on the bus
that he drove across town to buy her
those little yogurts that she likes I
asked kitty where to find those yogurt
drinks you like so much and well the
rest is pretty much history all in all
it's safe to say that Noah really
connected with his character especially
since he incorporated so many of his own
mannerisms into the movie according to
sources Noah is a natural flirt so these
sort of things just come easy to him the
popcorn scene it doesn't matter how
good-looking you are
if you aren't a nice person then your
appeal can start to fade in the end the
most attractive quality is respect and
consideration and folks Noah sent nao
has got both of these qualities down
packed by now many of us know that Noah
is a natural on camera so much so that
he can improvise without the slightest
direction if there's one scene that
costs people to fall for Peter in a
matter of seconds it's the movie night
popcorn scene when Lara Jean found out
that Peter had never seen sixteen
Candles before she made it a point to
have him over for a movie night as usual
Lara jeans younger sister tagged along
to watch the film with them during the
movie Peter asks Lara Jean and Kitty why
they even like it in the first place and
points out how racist one of the
characters are Kitty comes to the movies
defense and says why are you even asking
that question hello Jay crying after
hearing this Peter scoffs and proceeds
to say that he is much better looking
than him and Kitty replies you wish
afterwards
Peter throws a pillow at her and they
start to have a pillow fight but not
before Peter takes the bowl of popcorn
from the couch and places it on the
floor while many of us thought that this
kind gesture was scripted it was
actually improvised by Noah who didn't
want to make a mess on set in the end
Noah did this without thinking twice
because that's just the sort of guy he
is while most people wouldn't even
notice this act some fans caught it and
had to bring it to light after all it
isn't every day that a handsome young
man makes it a point to prevent a
popcorn spill while having a pillow
fight with his crushes younger sister
did you notice Peter put the popcorn on
the floor when you first watched to all
the boys I've loved before if so let us
know in the comments the spin for the
win
so here's the moment you've all been
waiting for you're finally going to find
out which incredible scene the charming
Noah sent a nail improvised on his own
while many of us would agree that
there's never a dull moment into all the
boys I've loved before there are some
scenes that are better than others one
that comes to mind is the iconic back
pocket spin author Jenny Han knew that
she wanted to incorporate Sixteen
Candles is hand in the back pocket
moment into her book which is why she
wrote it into her plot in the first
place
however while rehearsing for this
stellar moment Noah decided to try
something new and wowed the entire crew
do you remember when Peter put his hand
in Lara jeans back pocket
spin her around and then held her close
in front of the entire cafeteria well of
course you do that's not something you
can easily forget when Noah pulled this
move in front of director Susan Johnson
she immediately had the script rewritten
to incorporate his actions to say that
she was impressed by his natural
abilities to connect with his character
would be an understatement after all she
did have to add a handful of his moves
into the movie after seeing them come to
life the fact that Noah and Lana Condor
could add a piece of their own
personality to the movie makes it feel
all the more genuine before we part ways
we just wanted to tell you that the
entire to all the boys I've loved before
cast has talked about a possible sequel
after all Hans book is the first out of
three so keep your eyes open in the next
upcoming months because a sequel just
might get announced would you be
overjoyed if Laura Jean and Peter got
together to film their senior year of
high school or do you think that it's
impossible for a movie to ever come
close to the original let us know how
you feel in the comments oh and don't
forget to tell us which unscripted
moment was your favorite and that's it
for our video we hope you enjoyed the
show see you next time on the things
[Music]